[Music]
hi everyone as you heard my name is
marked ovulation I'm here all the way
from Melbourne Australia thank you so
much for having me here today in such a
beautiful city now one of my passions if
you follow me on twitter this is no
secret to you one of my passions is
design and particularly the intersection
of design with technology and how it
affects the way we build applications so
for the purposes of today what I really
want to talk about is rethinking design
practices in our daily work and what we
can do to help achieve this now I think
our industry is at a crossroads I talk
to a lot of people who are working in
the space and everyone says the same
thing everyone's struggling with this
our design systems aren't fully
delivering on their potential the more
and more we invest in design in code the
more we feel this disconnect between the
two disciplines and everyone's
struggling to make sense of it our
design is increasingly defined in code
this is something that we're pouring all
of our efforts into and yet design
workflows are struggling to keep up last
year I was here on this very stage
talking about how we can export from our
react based component library as we have
into a static design tool like sketch
and then I talked more about other
design tools that are trying to embrace
components as a first-class medium but
ultimately no one's fully cracked it yet
we're all struggling with this so our
industry has a choice to make there's
two radically different ways we can
tackle this problem the first is
obviously the most attractive at first
glance which is bringing code and the
work that we're doing into design tools
and this is what we're seeing with newer
tools like framer X but there's also
another angle which is actually
embracing code as a design medium and
designing in code itself designing a
code is the angle that I'm gonna look at
today and it's the one that really
excites me the most I think because I
think it really has the most potential
to change the way we think about design
as an industry and that's because by
working in design in code as a design
medium designers and developers will
literally speak the same language
Design Systems we talk a lot about
trying to speak the same language and
these new tools that we're looking at
might get some ways towards us thinking
the same ways but ultimately we express
ourselves very differently I think I
think if we break down the walls between
code and design there's a massive
opportunity there for us to change the
way we think and the way we work now I
work at seek in Melbourne in Australia
this is a this is a household name
obviously less than well known here it's
the leading job site there there and I
at seek I work on the design system
among other things braid is our design
system which is open-source
so if you want to go have a look at it
and see what we're doing in this boat in
this space please go check that out now
what I want to talk to you with today is
how we're solving this and some of the
hard lessons we've learned along the way
and what we're trying to do into the
future so hopefully this resonates with
you and it's something that you can take
into your work when you when you resume
that next week so this three top
high-level things I want to cover today
the first of which is tooling second
which is the extract abstractions you
need in your design systems to achieve
this this goal and the last is the
workflow that we want to build on top of
that so let's start at the top which is
with the tooling now it was actually
again on this stage last year that I
unveiled for the first time a tool that
I'd been working on and that we've been
using at seek called playroom now
playroom is a tool for letting you
design in the browser with components
that you've built but the key
differentiator over other tools is that
playroom treats JSX as a design tool
rather than trying to abstract it away
behind a drag-and-drop UI so in practice
it looks something like this you can see
there at the bottom a pane of JSX that
you can write and you have full access
to the component library that you've
plugged into it it supports theming
which is something that we needed for
our system so as you can see along the
top there there is an iframe for every
single thing off the screen to the right
if you were to scroll across you would
also see different screen sizes so it's
useful as a responsive design tool as
well so here you can see you at your
describing the UI in the components that
you've that you've developed and if you
find that something's missing it's up to
you to plug that in as part of your
component library so this has been an
invaluable tool for us to be able to get
our design systems circulated throughout
company and that's because of two
important factors the first one is that
it's zero install it's web-based so
people don't need to setup a complicated
developer environment this is
particularly important if you're trying
to reach out to non developers the fact
that they can just click a link from the
design system website and have that up
and running has been invaluable and the
second part of it of course being in the
web browser means that we are able to
have shareable URLs so someone can throw
together a UI design very quickly send
it to someone in slack and get some
feedback and maybe they change it send
it back and forth again this has been
invaluable for us to circulate the
knowledge of the design system within
the company for me as a developer
working on a component library this has
been a crucial tool for me to test drive
your design language so what what this
does for me is it lets me simulate that
end user experience of having a blank
canvas in theory if my design system is
powerful enough I should be able to
compose up a brand new UI from scratch
very quickly and if I can't then
obviously I have some more work to do
and this has been the best way for me to
get that feeling so the next thing I
want to talk about is abstractions and
of course the design system is
ultimately one big abstraction but it's
all the the big message I want to give
it cross to you today is that your job
as a design system developer is to
accurately model the way designers think
it's effectively domain driven design
for the world of visual design a
designers should be able to make sense
of the code you're writing and in order
to achieve this we need to build up in
layers of course but each of these
layers discretely needs to make sense
and from a designer's perspective so the
first stop along the way is design
tokens or you can think of these as your
theme variables so this is where you
centrally define your palette of
typography spacing color borders shadows
breakpoints things like this you could
go on and on
ideally this palette is relatively
limited design at scale is all about
constraints and limiting yourself to
that repeatable palette that that
ultimately defines your brand so a good
example of this is something like
spacing in a system rather than having
random numbers everywhere for spacing
things out you should try and constrain
yourself to a limited palette like this
this is actually the palette we use in
braid and you see we go from xx
all the way out to xx Lodge and all of
these are multiples of our grid which is
four pixels so that means that when
you're designing a UI you're pulling
from this pallet when you're spacing
things out there's a lot less room for
you to diverge across different screens
once you've got your design tokens in
place you can build up into primitives
which is where you ultimately wire them
up to components a big inspiration for
me in this space was styled system if
you haven't seen this this is really
incredible library we don't use it
ourselves but we've taken a lot of
inspiration from it and taking a lot of
ideas from it which is something I think
you should do either way regardless of
what you're doing at the end of the day
it really just boils down to this idea
of having a primitive component like box
which is what gives you the convenience
of pulling out these design tokens and
wiring them up to an element on the
screen as quickly and easily as possible
so as a practical example here we see in
playroom I'm rendering a box and I'm
setting a background color of positive
light and I'm setting the padding to be
medium so you'll notice here that I
don't have to create a style sheet and
wire it up to the element I don't have
to pull variables off a theme and put
them on the right CSS properties I just
have these top-level props on that
component ready to go with types defined
for that and everything given it in our
case it's writing a written in
typescript so this is a really good way
to speed up the development of new UI
and in a playroom environment means all
of your hard work is available to anyone
regardless of their development
expertise one of the best ideas of
styled system that you should definitely
steal is this idea of responsive props
basically the idea is this that if you
wanted to find padding for example on an
element typically you might pass a
single value of small or large but in
this case I'm passing an array literal
that has two values of small and large
so in this case what I'm saying is that
on mobile
I want the padding to be small and on
desktop I want the pattern to be large
again I'm not having to write a style
sheet here and I'm not having to write a
media query and make sure I've got all
the rules correct these sizes are
already predefined on our primitive
component and so now it's very
expressive for me at this higher level
to build up something as dynamic as this
so in practice again it looks like this
so there at that example we saw before
now we're using a responsive prop for
the padding and because I'm changing
that second value the mobile view is
staying untouched but the desktop
padding is changing so it gives you a
lot of flexibility very quickly to try
out different designs the goal here is
to make writing CSS the exception you
want to be operating at the component
level as much as you can and getting
these perimeters right is a key way to
enable this of course with these
primitives you're going to build higher
level things like buttons fields menus
and so on these things are a lot less
contentious they are easier to get right
they're much more easily understood by
non developers so I'm not going to go
into much detail here on this I'm going
to assume you should have not too much
trouble with these where things do get a
bit trickier though is when you come to
the world of layout this one takes a
little bit more consideration and in
fact in our case it took us quite a
while to really figure out the best
approach for this so this is ultimately
what we've landed on and for me that the
biggest inspiration here was a really
great article by Nathan Curtis from 8
shapes I called space in design systems
and he goes really deep on this topic of
how you look at a UI like this and break
it down into its discrete parts in terms
of whitespace what are the different
moving parts what do we call them how do
you standardize this and this is really
critical for us if we're trying to build
out design systems that make this sort
of layout as easy as possible one really
important rule if you want to do layout
well and I've learned this the hard way
as the components shouldn't contain
surrounding white space if you render a
component on the screen there should be
nothing around it in terms of white
space and that's because white space is
owned by layout components these are
these two concerns you need to separate
when it comes to to laying out a screen
and components but there's a problem
it's easy enough to get people to accept
this rule but the browser itself
actually breaks this rule right out of
the gate what do I mean by that so if I
render a piece of text and I inspect it
and developer tools this probably looks
normal to you this looked normal to me
until about a couple of months ago but
there's a big problem here this is
breaking the rule that we just said
which is having zero surrounding white
space on our components from a design
perspective if you talk to a designer
about this the top
of this of this element is the top of
the capital letter and the bottom of
this element visually is the baseline of
the text and yet the browser's given us
a chunk of white space at the top and a
chunk of white space at the bottom so
that means now that in our design system
without realizing it we're probably
going to be fighting this if you look
back at your work over the years once
you see this you'll probably realize
that you've spent a lot of time fighting
this problem so that means in practice
when you stack a bunch of headings for
example there's gonna be some space
between them it's gonna look something
like this now again this might seem
normal to you at first glance but
imagine if these were buttons for
example there would be zero space
between those buttons but because we've
used text here we have space between
them from a visual design standpoint if
you were critiquing this the first thing
you might notice is the fact that the
white space is not balanced around the
the internals of this card so the
left-hand gutter there is more narrow
than the space at the top and bottom of
the card and there's really no way for
us to fix this at the component level
the component itself the h1 in this case
is doing the wrong thing so how do we
fix this we've we've come up with a with
a solution internally for how we do this
there's two steps to it the first is we
use a transform to pull the text down so
that its baseline sits on the bottom of
the container and then we effectively
crop the top of the text node by
rendering a pseudo element before it
with a margin top of - a height
correction that we've calculated so I
vomited a bunch of calculations here
that you need to do based on the
properties of the font the cap height
and the descender height if you want to
see the the the specifics of this go
check out braid design system on github
and you'll see the the more long-form
version of this but that's really the
concept is pull the text down crop the
tip the top of the node off and so that
means that when we render our stack of
headings rather than H ones it's going
to behave more correctly in regards to
our system because now you'll see that
the top of that capital letter at the
very top of the card is balanced in
terms of white space of the top and the
left hand side there is no space between
each of those text nodes and then the
the baseline of that last one again is
evenly spaced with that left hand gutter
this is critical to building a system
that's predictable that works the way
designers think
ultimately our goal so the important
thing now is the text behaves like every
other component in our system so we're
free to build better abstractions on top
of this and we're mapping to the
designers mental model again ultimately
that's the goal of a design system now
that we've sorted out the white space
around text which is the most common
part of your UI we're free to build good
layout components on top so I'm going to
show you what this means in with a few
examples I'm gonna start with my
favorite which is the stack component
this is probably the most widely used
one in our system at a code level a
stack looks like this it's a component
that you wrap around a bunch of child
nodes and then you define the space
between them so visually it looks like
this so you can see here I've got a
heading I've got some text I've got an
action an action bar at the bottom and
I'm tweaking that space prop to go from
small medium large and so on and you'll
see that it's fanning out all of its
child nodes evenly but only space
between them not above and below so that
means that the top of that capital
letter on the heading title there is
hitting the top of the padding the
bottom of the padding of that card and
that marries up with what we see at the
bottom was the button hitting the the
padding at the bottom in line is another
good layout component which is used for
things like laying out badges at the top
of a card which you'll see shortly again
at a code level it looks the same as
stack you put a bunch of child nodes in
it you define the space between them but
in this case what an inline is for is
for flowing content like this so again I
talked about badges this is a very
common UI pattern so what we're saying
is that with a single prop we want to
evenly spaced spaced out horizontally
and vertically between our badges and
the key thing is that we're making sure
within this component that we don't
introduce that surrounding whitespace
that last line of badges will not have a
row of white space below at the bottom
of the container hits right up against
the bottom of those badges and if it
doesn't wrap then it takes up a single
line so now very quickly we can operate
at this fire level thinking like a
designer making a single decision that
impacts this entire component in terms
of spacing columns is a little easier to
deal with because everyone knows what
columns are
here's what it looks like now this one's
a lot simpler as I said but you'll see
here that that the layout is honoring
those design tokens that we've just
specified earlier so just by changing
this one prop the space between our
columns is fanning out evenly but the
great thing about our system building up
in layers is that the responsive props
that we defined as a feature down at the
box layer is potentially available up at
these higher components so in this case
the columns component actually does
support responsive props so if you want
to say that your columns have small
space between them on mobile and large
space on desktop you can express it as
easily as this which consumers if your
design system no doubt will appreciate
again the key thing here is that we
mapped to the designers mental model in
terms of the way they manage white space
because if you ever watch a designer
work they tend to drop the elements they
want on the screen as a first pass and
then as a second pass they're dealing
with the white space they're dealing
with the layout then they're nudging
things up and down to make sure that
things sit correctly on the screen and
this as a component system is basically
giving them that same mental model now
up to this point if you've done your job
well your components should make sense
to non developers they should be able to
look at the code that you're writing and
and be able to follow it completely and
not only that but they should actually
be able to start to roll up their
sleeves and write it themselves and
that's really the idea with this tool is
that you're creating an environment
that's a lot more inviting for people
who are not as experienced with
development because you've you've
trimmed away everything that's that's a
tricky about react in terms of your
development environment even the fact
that you have to write a function that
returns JSX is gone and you're just
writing the raw JSX and so now we have a
tool that we can use to bring other
people along with us on this journey and
start to learn the components in our
system and try them for themselves
I think this opens the opportunity for
us to start to make code part of the
design process if we've done our job
well this should be possible so to me
what this means is prototyping in code
there's still a room there's always
going to be room for pencil and paper at
the very least and even tools like
sketch are great for trying out rough
ideas before you want to invest
heavily but what I want to push for is
this idea of getting into codes sooner
than we do today often we treat code as
that as the is the thing we do at the
very end of a design process when we're
ready to ship to production I think we
need to change that around and get code
in there much much earlier than we do
today so how can we help there's a lot
of work here for us to do to make this
happen from a from a cultural
perspective I think we need to get
involved with design we need to start
sitting with designers in their own
spaces seeing how they work and really
trying to understand what they need from
the system hopefully you've been doing
this already to build a design system
but even when you've got that far you
can need to keep doing this this is
really critical in particular I think
you need to pay attention to how
designers iterate because if we if we
want to be able to design in code
our code needs to be flexible enough to
deal with all the different iterations
that they go through so keeping an eye
on this is really important this is
quite a big leap obviously and I'm very
aware of that and so what you need to do
is find those early adopters and offer
constant support to them so in our case
what we're doing is we're running a
slack channel internally for people who
need design support with our system and
we've tried to make it as much as
possible a place where people feel
welcome to ask questions to surface the
problems they're having to share
playroom links around and get feedback
and we've had some early wins there and
it's and it's been really positive for
us once you start to go out sell outside
that group of early adopters a really
good strategy is to encourage pairing
between designers and developers which
probably should be happening anyway but
this starts to give you a place to do
that in a dedicated way so if you sit
down a developer with a designer in
front of this tool and they start to try
and translate their early concept work
into JSX that feedback loop gets nice
and tight now what I want to what I want
to propose is this idea as jeaious this
idea of JSX as a design tool for
everyone not just for developers I think
it opens up the door to making our
design language something that can be
expressed very quickly and easily in a
way that really crosses this boundary
between design and development that
means us as a community need to welcome
designers into the fold at large and
within our
the companies we work in this is the
really critical step I think that we
need to get right getting things
technically right is not enough we need
to move the needle on the design process
itself and I really think there's an
opportunity here for us to do it in
order to do this we need to use code
oriented design tools maybe build them
for yourself if you need to you know
take playroom for kit and add your own
features if you like in our design
systems themselves we need to make sure
we create the right abstractions and
right meaning mapping to the way
designers think about things in order to
achieve that we need to work closely
with designers and make sure that we
really deliver on the potential that
they need and then finally we need to
actively support new workflows that are
opened up as a result of this it's
really our job to do this so if we
really want to do this if we really
really want to start rethinking design
practices you know this isn't going to
happen without the people in this room
so hopefully this is resonating with you
and hopefully you think this is
something that is possible and has the
potential to really improve the quality
of the products we ship to the end our
end users and let us move a lot faster
while we do it so I'm hoping you'll join
me on that journey and I'd love to
really change the way we think about
design that's it for me thank you for
listening and thank you Mark
dela gleesh everyone the co-creator of
TSS and Mark we have a bunch of
questions I like the idea of layout
components but don't developers get
worried about the extra Dom it brings um
yeah so I put this in the category of
I'm happy to cross that bridge when I
come to it you know I don't I'd I think
the bigger that you have two competing
problems here and there's always a cost
to abstractions but I think that this
abstraction is worth it but we'll say
our stack and inline based on the wild
card selectors know from memory we wrap
each child in a container I think but I
could be wrong
I'd have to double-check it's nice to
know that you have to double check
something yeah you know there are tools
for developers to help them use normal
web heading some design wouldn't be
easier to provide them this then
redefine basic fundamental element
so I'm not sure I understand the
question either you know I tend to not
to understand those questions let's be
honest you know I thought JavaScript was
something that Java wrote it's not I
know
I mean I'll adjust the last point I
guess redefine basic fundamental element
I actually think this is the crux of
some of the issues we have trying to
cross this divide because effectively
what you're doing is you're calling out
what the browser's doing natively as
being incorrect you know and and that
actually I would say that goes against
our nature to do that like I was kind of
I was unable to find this issue for
quite a while because I just took for
granted that that's you know that's the
way things work it's one of those things
you don't question but it took me
sitting with designers and really
talking through why they're struggling
with the design system and why it's not
doing what they expect to really
understand why this extra whitespace
around text nodes is a problem and now
that we've made that change for me
there's no going back I think that it
makes things all that much easier to
make predictable UI omaree of last
question and it plans to support other
css3 compilers besides gsx I'd say no
and I think that for me that the big
reason is that I I genuinely think JSX
is something that that actually makes
this possible so I've worked with react
without JSX before just using the
function syntax so I did that quite
early on and you know if I had to I
could make that work you know I'd still
be using react probably but I think what
JSX does is it really lowers the barrier
to entry for people who maybe have just
dabbled with a bit of HTML but coding
wasn't really their thing and I think
you get a lot of that in the design
space a lot of designers who've dabbled
with the web that haven't gone very deep
JSX I think makes it that much more
approachable for people who don't have a
technical background thank you so much
there was Mark Douglas
[Music]